you know some movies make me appreciate
the finer things in life while others
they make me appreciate movies like
skyline the Warriors way where to begin
now in the first three minutes of this
movie things were looking good they had
the whole ninja gaiden intro video vibe
you know two ninjas jousting one falls
you know sweet ninja [ __ ] and after
that's done an hour goes by before
anything happens after that
you think I'm joking now you're right
other things do happen the biggest
badass in the world plants flowers and
presses sheets that [ __ ] does not count
I might as well have been watching the
Angley Hulk so I'm pretty sure the
writer and director of this movie was
like I'm gonna make a movie that's like
300 and Ninja Assassin set in a western
setting with a circus I'm not lying
about this and in watching this movie
you realize that's kind of like saying I
like pizza hamburger eggs and ice cream
so I'm gonna blend it all together and
make the greatest meal shake ever in
reality you end up with a concoction
that kind of tastes like vomit or the
Warriors way this movie is actually a
few things just a ninja story that you
just don't give a [ __ ] about a Western
that you don't give a [ __ ] about a love
story that you don't give a [ __ ] about a
revenge movie who doesn't love those
that you don't give a [ __ ] about and
anything else that you can think of that
should have been cool that you end up
not giving a [ __ ] about with every shot
in the movie having shitty green screen
that's ultimately a failed attempt at
being stylish like 300 meets western
meets ninja [ __ ] I'm mad because I
wanted to like this movie it should have
been awesome and none of the characters
you just don't give a [ __ ] Kate Bosworth
is annoying as hell now southern accents
can be really cute or really annoying
she happens to be that second one
what's that even a southern accent I
don't know and I thought this movie was
gonna be subtitled to my surprise I was
really pissed that it wasn't now all the
overacting can be mine to enjoy or
endure and in the trailer to this movie
we were promised that the main bad guys
were gonna be ninjas knew there's these
Yosemite Sam types you know
types yeah then the ninjas are in it
briefly those bait-and-switch bastards
so in my humble opinion the Warriors
ways up there with Legion and skyline is
the worst movies of the year and it
definitely gets the [ __ ] Award but if
you like what you've seen here you want
to see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]